from a young love interest in harry
potter and twilight to the big and
serious lead of batman
i'm vengeance robert pattinson's career
evolution can be seen from the very
basic terms of a child actor
growing into an adult one wanting to
take on more serious roles
i am better than you today we're taking
a look at how his career has
importantly evolved through his
relationship to hollywood
and its ability to take him seriously as
an actor i mean it's
not exactly a job it's like i should be
paying to do this
pattinson's acting career itself started
with a rocky and unsure beginning
this dropping young lad must be cedric
am i right sir
his role in harry potter and the goblet
of fire initially put robert pattinson
on the map
as cedric diggory pattinson acted as
harry potter's main competition in the
goblet of fire
he's serious this role made him stand
out against the rest of the multitudes
of actors working on the hp
set and distinguished his name for many
viewers even though this role was very
influential on the trajectory of his
career
it seemed as though robert pattinson
really didn't care for it
as a young star especially in interviews
rob had a very casual air about him that
came across as apathetic
or indifferent yeah i think this is the
best movie
well it is even in regard to his
establishing role as a face in hollywood
it seems as though from the get-go
pattinson didn't take his roles or his
career very seriously and that hollywood
didn't take him seriously as an actor
either
the harry potter franchise turned out to
be the origin of pattinson's success
but after a few months of looking he was
having a hard time getting another job
in the film industry
after attending audition after audition
with no luck
robert pattinson's talent agent
suggested he carried around a guitar
with him to set him apart from the pack
and demonstrate his potential skills as
a musician this attention-grabbing move
on the part of pattinson was taken
more or less poorly by the producers of
twilight the filmmakers questioned the
presence of pattinson's instrument
during his audition
which put a pretty big dent in his
confidence in fact
rob called his parents convinced he
didn't land the role and told them he
was considering giving up on acting
altogether
thankfully that period of discouragement
didn't last long because rob got a call
from the filmmakers soon after that he
had secured the role of edward in the
twilight series
i never really quite knew how to play a
vampire though
the criticism the young actor received
in his audition for edward
is clearly demonstrative of the way in
which the industry viewed pattinson
as a young boy who doesn't need to be
taken seriously just as pattinson hadn't
taken his first role earnestly
his second big role regarded him in the
same way and even he had lots of trouble
taking it seriously after a while
everything about me invites you in
my voice my face even my smell
throughout the filming of twilight it
began to become more and more obvious
that pattinson was restless within his
role as edward
according to interviews rob was almost
fired from the twilight franchise
after being chastised for taking his
role too seriously
the producers came up to the young star
and told him that if he were to remain
working for the film production
he would need to loosen up be more happy
and drop the brooding attitude he'd
adopted for the role
as a young star you can imagine it would
be challenging and almost impossible to
stick up for yourself to new bosses who
just gave you a second chance at success
sorry i can't remember anything today
in this interview rob tells howard stern
that he eventually just gave into the
pressure to be more lighthearted
came back off i came back after lunch
was like hi
i want to keep my job since that point
in time it seems robert really leaned
into the light-heartedness that his
superiors expected of him in his role as
edward
in nearly any interview you can find on
the internet pattinson has something
snarky or comical to say about his time
on set and the twilight portion of his
career
video compilations have gone viral
across the internet since pattinson's
career ended with the twilight series
they show him poking fun at the
franchise laughing at the narrative
and generally regarding the movie series
with little respect
when i read it it seemed like it was a
book that wasn't supposed to be
published
this shows how patinson fought fire with
fire during his time as edward
the producers of twilight didn't want
him to be taken seriously so he would
make twilight out to be the most
unserious project he's worked on
regardless of this treatment
there's no denying that twilight set
patinson up to be the new heartthrob of
hollywood
with twilight fanatics knowing every
detail of his livelihood
and paparazzi tracking him down rob had
to deal with a whole new level of fame
after his work with this franchise
fame that kept him locked down as edward
to the public despite his effort to
distance himself from the character
that's exactly what will lead us into
the twist in rob's evolution
his desire to distance himself from
edward and being characterized as a
lighthearted actor
just takes time to realize how to live
when your life kind of
seismically shifts like
[Music]
pattinson's next career move was
undoubtedly reactionary to his time
playing edward
as he gave up the role of on-screen
crush and took on the independent movie
world
with more serious dark and challenging
characters to play and roles to fill
in his time filming and working on
smaller independent productions
it seems as though rob was able to grow
within himself and find more respectable
footing as an actor
the roles he was able to take on in
various films including good time
high life the lighthouse and the king
all granted the actor a larger sense of
professionalism
good time a 2017 independent film by
production company a24
received a huge amount of critical
acclaim with pattinson and other lead
actors receiving a six
minute standing ovation at the film's
premiere at the cannes film festival
the directors of good time actually
built the film around pattinson's
interest
proving that at least in the independent
film world pattinson was gaining
industrial respect for his craft
sort of overwhelmed and with enthusiasm
and they said okay we're going to come
up with something for yeah yeah and he
was bait the director was saying
in his other film high life pattinson
also hunted down the director to get
started working with them for the film
project
director claire dennis said she felt an
initial reluctance to hire pattinson
as she assumed he would be expecting a
lot from her and her directorial skills
while pattinson says and then i spent
probably
four years trying to get a meeting which
never happened
it's obvious that at least in this point
in his career pattinson was seeking out
directors he felt could better him as an
actor
and help him grow into a more serious
name than he touted before
pattinson was not only demanding better
quality work from the creators in the
independent film industry
he was also delivering better work and a
more serious affect towards the projects
he was working on
his aim to become a better actor by
taking himself
and the industry more seriously seems to
be paying off
in the king it is obvious that
pattinson's acting has taken on a new
layer of talent
i have come to describe
for you you're in days
as his lines are delivered with variety
and life unseen before in his role as
edward
in interviews about his more recent work
including the independent film the
lighthouse
pattinson's tone and general regard to
the projects he's invested in
is very different from the way in which
he treated harry potter or twilight
he talks about movies as though they are
serious projects that he is excited to
be part of
sort of weird slapstick humor at the
same time
i was like how is this all gonna meld
together his serious tone translates
over to his interviews about batman
wherein the actor is equally insightful
and serious about his work
it's interesting what the different
directions you can take with it and that
kind of
fit in someone's quite a specific
character in this clip
pattinson discusses the nuances of his
role as batman the intimidating shoes he
has to fill
and the director's unique perspective on
the narrative all of these topics differ
so greatly from his nonchalant
dismissive attitude about his roles or
the stories of harry potter and twilight
the batman trailer itself distinguishes
the movie as a much more serious toned
superhero flick
that is almost unlike anything pattinson
has acted in before
this isn't just another run-of-the-mill
superhero film
that is typically light-hearted full of
fun action and optimistic
rather this version of batman's
narrative is much more intense and
gloomy
the batman is characterized as brooding
violent and mysterious
i'm vengeance interestingly enough this
is much more like the energy patenson
tried to elicit for his character in
twilight which
almost got him fired this iteration of
batman takes the classic idea of the
superhero and transforms it into
something much more dark and serious
than past franchises have
making pattinson and his newfound somber
attitude towards acting
a perfect match for this role robert's
role as batman demonstrates and
solidifies the seriousness the actor has
been working towards during his time
acting in independent films
to summarize his evolution it is
important to identify the type of movie
that robert pattinson started off with
and what these roles had in common
both of these movies set pattinson up as
the love interest
who doesn't have much going on except
for his romantic life and his looks oh
now i'm pissed
twilight played into this cliche a bit
more but harry potter determined
pattinson as a one-dimensional figure
that represents competition
this competitiveness plays into
pattinson's stereotypical heartthrob
casting
because romance in movies almost always
involves competition for love
maybe he wanted to go to the ball with
me
i'm sorry but someone's already asked me
these characters are useful roles for
people looking for a one-time claim to
fame
which is exactly what pattinson got
after his time in twilight
however robert pattinson put in a lot of
work to change the fate that the roles
he took on in twilight and harry potter
promised him
the characters that pattinson is now
taking on are almost the complete
opposite direction of his initial roles
they are steeped in seriousness and give
off the feeling of hard-boiled realism
his character in good time is complex
and adds to the film's sense of
anxiousness
in the lighthouse his character takes on
a seriousness that pattinson has rarely
shown in his acting career before
you ain't no copper you ain't the
president you ain't my father
those films including high life the king
and now batman
all work to elevate pattinson's acting
skills as well as his regard toward his
career
from cliche heartthrob to various
characters steeped in hard-boiled
realism
pattinson has gone from an actor that
wasn't taken seriously to one of the
most reputable young faces in acting
his current roles reflect hard work and
dedication from the actor that has
allowed him to set himself apart from
all the dreamboats that come and go
through hollywood
what iteration of rpat is your favorite
let us know what you think in the
comment section below
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things for more great content about your
favorite tv shows and movies
we'll see you next time